in the far reaches of Southern
[Music]
India the Moonlight conjures of Many
Wonders of the animal
kingdom along with terrifying
nightmares in this vast
Forest cut by
Rivers like bleeding veins
deadly
Arenas filled with violent
[Music]
conflict in a single night the
inhabitants of this mystical
landscape fight for their
lives this is a wild side of India that
few ever
see
a wild kind of magic permeates one of
the planet's largest
biospheres an environment populated by
the Wizards and witches of the animal
[Music]
kingdom this is the Wilderness of
Southern
India where there is always more to see
than me the
[Music]
ey as the Golden Light of the fading Sun
washes over the
landscape the dark magic of the Coming
Night disrupts the beauty
queuing Hunters could take to the skies
the water and the
land this sudden burst of evening
activity is a signal to many to seek
shelter
because once night sets in their world
violently
transforms nowhere is the Strange Magic
here more apparent than up in the trees
these towering citadels are home to a
variety of Waring factions and lone
Wanderers and the most epic battles take
place on the small
stage one you can only see if you look
closely when you're a tiny bug in a big
tree you need unique skills to give you
an
[Music]
edge and few are more unique than those
possessed by a
master of
[Music]
Illusion this Bug Hunter knows that the
best way to trick his prey
is to blend in perfectly with his
[Music]
surroundings this is the Indian stick
mantis but looking like a twig isn't
enough he has the atlic one
too so he barely moved
waiting for his prey to come
[Music]
close lucky for the Cockroach he's not
on tonight's
menu the Mantis has spotted something a
little more his size nearby
moving closer to his Target is
risky if the stick mantis breaks his
spell he'll expose
himself the some targets are worth
it
[Music]
he inches forward
and pays the ultimate
[Music]
price this is the Slender
Loris and he's a bug's worst
nightmare
the nocturnal primate gets his name for
his long lean
limbs andus things and the trees are
Beyond his
[Music]
reach to stay hidden from his
prey he uses a smelly
camouflage masking his scent by bathing
in his own
urine he's a small Hunter with a big
apple
appetite and he eats up to six prey
items a
minute but there's more than bugs on his
menu he also enjoys
[Music]
reptiles
young tree lizards wake up to The
Killing Spree unfolding in their tree
home they need their rest because
they've been up all
day but sleep is
impossible while the Slender Loris hunts
[Music]
nearby
the young lizards stick to the
Shadows but the lores won't stop hunting
till
sunrise
and it's only a matter of time before he
sees one of these meteor reptilian
options unfortunately for the lizards
they can't hide
forever
the LA spots the young reptiles who run
for their
lives
but in the trees there's not many
Avenues of
[Music]
escape and one of the baby tree lizards
reaches a dead
end
[Music]
a young Tree Lizard awakens to a living
nightmare as the Slender Lars hunts them
through their
tree
there's nowhere else to
[Music]
go and the Slender lorus sends the young
lizard to an early grave
but there are others in this tree just
as Rous as the predatory
primate but he's not sticking around to
meet this ghoulish
[Music]
be it grips the branches with skeletal
clawed hands and
[Music]
feet
this is one of the largest bat species
on the
planet the Indian flying
fox with a four foot
wingspan in sharp claws he looks
ferocious but he spends his nights on
the hunt for a sweeter kind of
Flesh the
Flesh of
fruit his diet consists solely of it and
these jack fruit trees are an easy
[Music]
target but these huge ORS of pulpy fruit
are Ground Zero for V vent
confrontations flying foxes can't resist
jack fruit as evidenced by their many
scars and territorial male bats fight
each other for the best
purches this male scrambles towards his
prize but he has to eat fast because at
any moment his competition might swoop
in and challenge him for this food Rich
Branch the jack fruit makes a
sacrificial
offering transferring its Offspring to
one of the best seed dispersers in the
world while it's eaten
[Music]
alive but his Feast is about to
[Laughter]
end as other bats approach ready to
fight for their share of the
bounty
the notoriously noisy bats battle each
other upside
down and their fighting rocks the entire
canopy
but this is a Turf that's already
claimed and they've awakened a
horrifying
threat a couple ants might not look like
much but they're just a small part of a
much larger
[Music]
Army
and this Army can devour just about
anything in its
[Music]
path hundreds of giant bats fight over a
tree bounty
in the canopy of Southern
[Music]
India the mischievous flying foxes cause
chaos wherever they
[Applause]
go
[Music]
this tree is home to a colony of
Weaver and the bats have drawn them out
from their Fortress like
Nest woven together with silk and leaves
their nest can support an army of ants
nearly a half a million
strong and these Warriors will do
anything to protect their
own with the troops alerted soldier ants
flood onto the branches to battle
anything that's moving
nearby
the bats leave other tree dwellers who
can't fly away to deal with the mess
they've
created everyone from dragonflies to
cockroaches suddenly find themselves
fighting for their
lives
they seek islands of safety amongst
swarming Weaver ants but there are few
places to
[Applause]
[Music]
hide Andy Ant have long range weapons
they spray missiles of costic acid which
disorientates and weakens their
targets the slug might have escaped but
there are plenty of other dinner options
nearby
[Music]
to take down prey many times their size
the ants work together as
one first they pinned down the kitty
did's feet so he can't hop
away wow while some ants keep a tight
grip on his legs others bombard him with
their
acid weakening their trophy catch before
the Final Phase of this coordinated
assault when morans move in to butcher
him
alive
it's a death by a Thousand
Cuts the ant can carry items more than a
100 times their body weight working
together hauling this catch back to the
nest is an easy
task but the Hunt's not over
[Music]
a gecko's been spotted by forward
Scouts
[Music]
is
another gecko watches in
horror as the assembly line of death
tears apart his
relative is time to get off the
tree but there are few avenu news of
Escape he's run out of
options he has to
jump the gecko lands
safely but he's still in
danger because a forest floor can be
even deadlier than the
trees
creatures rivaling those from the
darkest fantasies roam this mysterious
terrain and they're always
hungry
a gecko escapes an army of death high in
the
branches only to land in a lirer of
nightmares nestled into the base of a
tree in Southern
[Music]
India the gecko's presence awakens the
inhabitants of this Sinister place
[Music]
this massive eight-legged Hunter quietly
Maneuvers closer to its
visitor
[Music]
this is an Indian ornamental a tarantula
species that can grow to be larger than
a human
hand and she's more than happy to greet
her
guests the Geo
freezes but it's only a matter of time
before she makes her
[Music]
[Applause]
move
[Music]
this is a threat the gecko can't escape
the tarantula injects him with her
Venom a paralyzing toxin that
immobilizes her prey making it easier
for her to dig
[Music]
in Sunrise is still 2 hours
away and other nightmares lurk in the
heart of the rotting
tree one that beats to the rhythm of a
busy
Colony this tribe isn't as ferocious as
the Weaver
ANS but they attract a killer and that's
even more
terrifying including one
who wears a
[Music]
disguise this diabolical Hunter wasn't
born with his
camouflage he made it with dirt and
debris
he's an assassin
bug but he has a way to go before he's a
master of his camouflage
craft unlike another of his kind
nearby who's taken their art of
concealment to to a gruesome
level this more experienced assassin bug
builds his
disguise with the corpses of his
[Music]
victims the rookie observes the master
whose cloak of Rotting Flesh also hides
his
scent
and he's looking for others to add to
his Twisted
[Music]
tapestry he captures an ant and injects
it with enzymes that dissolves its
organs
once fed the veteran adds another
carcass to his terrifying
[Music]
armor the stench of death also Shields
him from
predators like the huntsman
spider the veteran suit of the Dead
hides
him but the rookies
exposed because the huntsman spider
isn't fooled by just a little
dirt
membership in this league of Assassins
doesn't mean a place at the top of the
food
chain and the Huntsman devours the
smaller
[Music]
killer every tree in forest is a unique
Battleground but they're part of a much
larger
landscape and the horrors of the forest
floor have fewer
boundaries Scavenging under the
Moonlight is a double-edge sword
because while the darkness provides
cover it also conceals one of the
deadliest Hunters on the
[Music]
planet assassins and diabolical
tricksters hunt in the Trees of Southern
India
but the deadliest Predators lur below
them in the Dark Shadows of the forest
floor with an hour left till sunrise a
Bandicoot rat risks her life to to
forage through this dangerous
[Music]
terrain she works hard all night because
she has other mouths to
[Music]
feed
it's tough being a single mother out
here because she has to consume more
than 5% of her body weight to sustain
herself while nursing her
young the baby bandicoots are most
vulnerable while she's out
Scavenging even though she stays close
to the entrance of their
home there are Hunters who can slip by
undetected the mother Bandicoot
continues her foraging unaware of the
deadly Invader slithering
nearby
[Music]
this venomous serpent can grow to be
almost 7 ft
long and his scent receptors have have
picked up on an irresistible
[Music]
rumor
the mother Bandicoot spots the threat on
her
[Music]
doorstep
the spectacle
Cobra the Bandicoot is no match for the
most iconic snake on the
planet she leads him on a
chase
but she can't run
forever she has to make a
choice face the mysteries of the
deep or
death by
Venom
face with certain death on
Shore the desperate mother takes her
chances in an Indian
River a place of strange new
dangers a mother Bandicoot rat leaps
into a dark
abyss to escape the strike of a
spectacle
Cobra but this snake can
swim the Bandicoot rat climbs onto a
life
raft
but it barely keeps her above the
water and monsters lurk
[Music]
below the spectacle Cobra senses their
presence and returns to shore leaving
the Bandicoot rat to deal with this new
Danger
a school of African sharptooth
[Music]
catfish this invasive species can grow
to be nearly 6 ft
long and their whiskers are covered in
taste buds allowing them to sample their
prey before moving in for the
kill the Bandicoot rat clings to her
precarious
perch and as long as she's above
water she has a
[Music]
chance
but as the capti
investigate bubbles from their gills and
the splashing of their fins Rock the
branch and if the rat falls off she's as
good as
dead
what
but the catfish mysteriously
descend a calm before
storm
because something else
[Applause]
approaches the mugger
crocodile these massive reptiles rule
the
river and they can't resist a school of
[Music]
catfish the mother rat is caught in the
middle
you
and she sees a narrow Avenue of Escape
through the
chaos
f
despite her Valiant efforts the mother
rat's luck finally wears
out the circle of life extracts a heavy
t as her death leaves her young
orphaned and doomed to
starvation but the wild isn't without
mercy and the spectacled Cobra returns
to the unguarded
burrow to put these young Bandicoot
rats out of their
[Music]
misery
Sunrise breaks the incantations of
[Music]
darkness and another night in the forest
of Southern India
ends but in a magical world where few
things are as they
seem d danger forever lurks in the
open and in the
shadows ready to cast its deadly
[Music]
spells